yeah carly carly her best friend i know
is really struggling and i'm you know my
heart goes out to her
because i know what it's like to lose a
best friend and um
you know especially when you're trying
to save them and i i know that
when i found out she was there i knew
nikki was here on the last lockdown you
know she told me not to say
and um she was getting care you know but
um
yeah she rang me up and was like peter
miller to come and get me
in the clinic and uh
well you know i was busy at the time but
then this
this second lockdown happens and um
yeah i remember seeing that
uh seeing the fundraiser that carly and
leon had
made to get her i was like oh my god
she's really really ill man so
i was in london at the time and i just
rushed i just went got in the cab and
went over there with my my girlfriend
who's a mental now health nurse and we
just
try to you know give her as much love
and support and
um and because it's me you know me and
nicki had you know a great connection
with so i thought that i'd the love i
you know would just
boost her up and get her out of the
darkness you know and because this
lockdown has been really hard for
people with mental health issues like
this is really highlighted here you know
look
look what it's done you know i mean it's
taken one of the you know
one of the best characters the the
world's ever you know seen it look
this is rubbish man you know so um heart
goes out to all our friends i'm getting
so many nice messages
as well in my inbox um and um
thank you so much for the lovely support
that all her fans
and the big brother seven fans have been
giving me and
to the rest of the big brothers cast
we've all been getting so much love and
we really appreciate it i can say that
we were all really cut up and i'm
i just yeah i can't really put into
words it's still really quite a sore
subject
it's estimated that over 1.25 million
people are struggling with eating
disorders at any given time
and it is really important that we raise
awareness around eating disorders and
that those people
have somewhere to go and get help and
feel that they can do so
and often when we when we do talk about
eating disorders what we
what we don't necessarily look at is is
something like this where it does lead
to death but i mean obviously that that
happens
far too often do you think we don't take
these conditions seriously enough
sadly anorexia nervosa has the highest
mortality rate of any mental health
illness
it is a very serious health condition
all mental health is eating disorders
are very complex mental health disorders
and they need specialist intervention
which is why i would really encourage
anybody who's suffering or anybody who
sees a family member or friend suffering
to seek help at the earliest opportunity
and what help is out there
because i mean it is clearly for people
who are seeing themselves
in a very different light to how the
world sees them
a huge obstacle to get over
absolutely the first step is to see your
gp
there is a lot of information on beats
website
which can help in understanding what
condition you may be suffering with
and can give you some vital information
about how to communicate this with your
doctor
but getting to your doctor and getting a
referral for an eating disorder service
is the first point of call and the
sooner that happens
the generally the the faster and more
sustained recovery can be
is it possible is it ethical for someone
to to step in
on behalf of somebody else because it it
is very difficult to take that initial
step i would imagine for someone to say
i have a problem can someone step in and
say
my loved one has a problem
definitely the first thing i would
recommend would be to actually have a
conversation with your loved one try and
pick a time that isn't around
meal time and isn't a contentious point
of the day
but again the beat website has got some
guidance for anybody
who needs to talk to somebody and raise
the fact that they think they may have
an issue
and will give advice and support about
doing that
um it has been shown that family
intervention
and the support of close family and
friends can really really aid somebody's
recovery
so if somebody close to you is suffering
then i would absolutely say yes have
that conversation
and support them what what sort of
recoveries can people see i mean can
is there a bright future for people is
there a sustained recovery for people
yes we believe recovery is possible we
know a lot of people who have suffered
very badly with eating disorders
and can then go on to lead a relatively
normal life
um there's always an awareness and a
need to monitor mental health as as we
all
need to do but recovery is absolutely
possible
the key to that being a full and
sustained recovery as i say
is getting that treatment early getting
help and getting support
will really aid that recovery